almost all American journalism is
controlled by a few massive corporations
news voice is a one-of-a-kind mobile app
that tracks the bias and corporate
interests that infuse the news stories
we consume every day and it's completely
free to use go to news voice dot-com
slash Pakman to download it hey this is
pretty funny and also kind of sad over
the last few days as we've seen the
virus become more and more of a crisis
in the US and around the world the Trump
administration and many Republicans and
many media outlets right-wing media
outlets immediately called for the types
of programs that they often oppose that
they sometimes even call socialism and
this includes simply sending people cash
right sending people checks that they
can deposit suspending foreclosures on
mortgages discussions about what do we
do about rent payments what do we do
about people who work for tips all of
this stuff where the answer is we've got
to just start sending people money or
telling them hold on to the money don't
don't send it to us or to wherever it is
that the money might be due um now it's
correct for this to be done this has to
be done as I've made clear before things
that we previously can't afford now we
all of a sudden can't afford not to and
we need to as soon as possible do it and
start sending the money around that
that's fine I get that the situation is
changing and people are realizing we
actually can't afford this stuff and we
need to do it it just so happens though
that many of the people that are
basically now talking about the type of
program that 2020 Democratic
presidential candidate Andrew yang
suggested he called that universal basic
income a lot of those people were
laughing at Andrew yang when he was
proposing it now I want to be really
clear okay Andrew yang talked about
$1,000 a month
to everybody as a permanent program the
discussion now is not that okay it's you
know one time or two payments of a
thousand bucks each
$2,000 one-time payment somebody's
proposing 3,000 somebody's proposing
6,000 depends who you talk to to call
the emergency cash that's being proposed
now universe
so basic income would be inaccurate
they're not the same thing
but when you hear Republican Mitt Romney
saying we should give everybody a
thousand bucks right away it obviously
brings back memories from just months
ago when Andrew yang was saying give
people a thousand dollars a month so I
have a hilarious clip from Fox News
where host dana perino glitches when
juan williams the token supposedly fost
he's a pretty centrist guy on fox news
he says isn't this what andrew yang was
talking about and you all called it
socialism and dana perino sort of
glitches and then she just says no it's
very funny because he rightly points out
you all made fun of andrew yang for
talking about just giving people money
to stimulate the economy and to improve
people's circumstances when he proposed
it and now you all are proposing it
admittedly on a different basis and with
a different time frame check it out for
the health of people then of course we
have to do everything to help for their
economic health on the other side work
what we make in front of this though
when andrew yang suggested something
like it was socialism no what no when he
was saying send $1,000 there there are
people who think that universal basic
income is actually a pretty good idea
I don't think of it as necessary
socialism especially if you look at it
that in Alaska how they give back money
but there'll be plenty of time to figure
it out but to Dickens point $1,000 for
people who really that's if they're
gonna need more than that
I agree Greg all right you sort of hear
the record skip when he says it and of
course this is what people were saying
to me on Twitter a couple days ago
people are saying David this is nothing
like any of the things that are that
were proposed by Democrats this is
temporary stimulus this is not universal
basic income this is not meant to be
permanent I get it but look at the way
that Dana Perino adds you know maybe
universal basic income isn't really a
bad idea a lot of people think it is a
good idea and look at what Alaska does
Alaska sort of does it and it's not
considered socialism
that's right Dana that's what we've been
saying it's not really socialism but at
the same time think about it on a deeper
level
whether you are for or against universal
basic income and of course recognizing
universal basic income if we did it it
wouldn't solve the circumstances that
led to such inequality in the first
place right the wealth disparities we
have aren't going to be solved by
sending people a thousand bucks a month
we've talked about that before it seems
everybody is now agreeing that universal
basic income isn't socialism but
hilariously the example Dana uses oil
profits in Alaska being redistributed as
a dividend to all Alaska residents that
is way closer to socialism than anything
Andrew yang has proposed because you are
socializing a portion of the profits
from the oil industry when you say
Alaska has oil revenue and even if
you're not involved merely because you
live in Alaska you will be entitled to a
portion of that revenue of that profit
that is socializing a piece of that
industry now again clearly a stimulus
package in an emergency is obviously not
social socialism it's also not universal
basic income but it has been remarkable
how instantly these pull yourself up by
your bootstraps right wingers have
changed their tune I tweeted yesterday
it's been really difficult over the last
week or two weeks to find anti-vaxxers
and to find libertarians that are still
touting their keep the government
completely out of it I know they exist
and I know you know when I say that
people will say David look at this
libertarian or that one but by and large
we are hearing very little from the
anti-vaccine wait for a vaccine to be
developed and rightly so they should
they should be shutting their mouths and
mostly they happen and we've been
hearing very little from the the extreme
libertarians who say the government
should have no role to play here this is
why we can't ever listen to them none of
their talking points are actually a
political philosophy it's a combination
of vapid talking points that sort of
sound okay in the moment to them
combined with posturing and there's not
really an underlying political
philosophy or that they stick to beyond
own the libs and justify post facto what
whereas we think makes sense at the time
now last thought on this and I don't
want to devote a lot of time to this
today historically when we have seen
socially conservative and economic
populist regimes they are pretty ugly
regimes I don't want to do that analysis
yet but something to think about is if
we see a lot of these socially
conservative movements like the American
evangelical right you know fox news etc
if we see them actually adopt some
economic populism historically that's
been pretty dangerous and some of the
worst regimes in history have been
socially conservative and sort of
economic populist at least in the way
that's being discussed now that doesn't
mean anything in particular I'm not
playing any kind of doomsday scenario
out but think we'll deal with this more
next week check out as we see the
Republican Party in the in the context
of this crisis and pandemic become more
economically populist while remaining in
principle socially conservative do a
little research into some of the other
socially conservative economically
populist regimes of the last hundred and
fifty years there's some pretty ugly
stuff there and just something that
we're thinking about I've been reading
about and maybe I'll talk to you more
about next week let's take a quick break
remember if you are not following the
david pakman show on twitch you might be
missing live streams follow me at twitch
TV
david pakman